I first went to Bell Labs I think in
1967 I had I was at the time a graduate
student in computer science except it
was before computer sighs it was
Electrical Engineering at Princeton and
I was lucky enough to get a summer job
at Bell Labs but it was a wonderful
place because there were an enormous
number of really good people doing
really interesting things and nobody
telling you what to do that's kind of a
rewarding environment and so it was so
good that when I graduated from
Princeton
I didn't even interview any other place
I just said okay I'll go to Bell Labs
they offered me a job why not do it and
that was a decision that was extremely
lucky and I've never regretted it in one
single largest building there were
probably 4,000 people of whom about
2,000 were probably PhDs in various
forms of science physics chemistry
materials and then on the call of the
softer and mathematics and the
relatively new field of computer science
at that point large number of really
really excellent people and the
environment was you can do anything you
want because the revenue source for Bell
Labs was very stable it was part of AT&T
which in effect provided telephone
service for the whole country and the
way it did at that time AT&T was a
regulated monopoly which meant that they
had in effect a guaranteed rate of
return and they peeled a tiny piece of
that off for research to improve
telephone service in the country that
was the quid pro quo and because of that
there was no shortage of resources and
no management direction that said you
have to do something that will save the
company in the next quarter that was
really very satisfying and so most
people worked on things that were in
some way long term or at least whose
immediate application wasn't obvious
hard to beat that environment I think
and I think I was there for over 30
years and I was never once told what I
should be working on the way it worked
is at the end of each year you had to
write down on one side one piece of
paper what you had done during the year
and they used that to determine how much
they pay you next year
I was born in Toronto as almost
everybody in Canada seems to be and I
went to university at University of
Toronto and I was there from 60 to 64
and then not knowing what to do in the
best tradition and not wanting to look
for a job I went to graduate school and
so I wound up at Princeton I think
largely because they made me on the
surface and in retrospect really a
better offer than some of the other
places that I had also applied to and
and that was a very good thing I
actually enjoyed that and I met a lot of
good people and by pure luck I landed
this job at Bell Labs the reason I
landed the job there I think is that the
year before I had worked at MIT on
project Mac which was the very first
real mob that was the beginning the
multics era and they were using
something called CTS s the compatible
time sharing system which was really the
first time sharing system and so I had a
good time that summer and I met
indirectly virtually people from Bell
Labs and so I got lucky and got a job
for a couple of summers and that paid
off both in future contexts but also
giving me something to do for my thesis
the original computing world orginal of
a long time ago certainly when I was an
undergraduate was that there were big
computers sitting in rooms air
conditioned rooms behind counters looked
after by operators and if you wanted to
get something done what you had to do
was take usually a deck of cards
although perhaps paper tape take it hand
it to an operator and a long time later
you would get your results which of
course would be it didn't work until
you'd repeat it and so the idea of time
sharing was to say let us make it so
that here's this computer sitting there
and instead of feeding it cards by an
operator let's connect terminals to it
and these were mostly at that time
mechanical terminals like teletypes not
even VDT types and connect those and
have the operating system of the
computer sort of give you a few seconds
or half a second of time then give him a
half and then give her a little bit just
go round and round the people who wanted
to do some kind of computing and because
computers were even then much faster
than people this actually gave everybody
the illusion that they had the whole
computer to themselves so it was
unbelievably liberating you could type
some stuff into a file and it would
remember it for you know punch card and
then you could say gee let me compile
that file and it would do that and a few
seconds later the compilation would be
over and no waiting for an operator to
give you a piece of paper that said your
compilation failed you found out right
away so then you made a change and did
it again and so it was incredibly more
productive you could do in a few minutes
something that might have taken you a
few days with the punch card paper
operator kind of mechanism so that's
what time sharing was if you like so
could you call that an early version of
cloud computing perhaps you could
there's the central computer it has the
resources that's where information is
being stored and you're talking to it
remotely now maybe not very remotely but
given phone systems it could be really
remotely so in an early sense you could
say that was cloud computing so you come
around full set in some respects
absolutely the connection was that MIT
had done this system called CTS s very
successful but of course very local and
they decided that they wanted to do the
next thing which was a computing utility
which would provide that same sort of
wonderful service to the world at large
let's build a computing utility and to
do that we need more resources of time
money and especially people and so MIT
enlisted two other organizations to help
them build this thing which is going to
be called multics the multiplexed
information and computing service one of
those was General Electric who at the
time made computer hardware seems
strange and the other was Bell Labs
which had at the time a lot of
experience in operating system
development because they had built
operating systems for IBM computers that
were not IBM and so we had this three
organizations MIT GE and Bell Labs in
three different places one was in
Cambridge Massachusetts one was in
Murray Hill New Jersey and one was in
Phoenix Arizona you don't have to study
management Theory very much to realize
that potential problems in this sort of
thing so they worked on multics for
probably three or four years and at
Point Bell Labs decided that it wasn't
going where it should go fast enough and
they withdrew from the project that was
in late 68 very early 69 but up to that
point people from Bell Labs who had been
involved in multix were had you know
really got used to time sharing
understood that that worked really well
had learned a lot of things about how
you develop operating systems we're
using high-level languages to do the
actual implementation of the operating
systems they got a tremendous amount of
experience and a taste for really good
computing and so when Bell Labs pulled
out it left people in particular Ken
Thompson and Dennis Ritchie with a big
hole we'd like to do things this way we
can't do it what do we do and then you
go often to this well told story of Ken
Thompson finding a little-used pdp-7
upon which he builds in a month an
operating system and the rest is UNIX
history at the time I was at MIT which
was the summer of 66 I did not know Ken
at all I met him I think then when I
spent the summer of 67 at Bell Labs and
we were in the same organization and I
think Denis arrived more or less the
same time I don't have clear memories of
that and then I went there permanently
in the very early in 1969 and we were
all in the same organization and so at
that point I got to know them well and
still friends Denis unfortunate died
several years ago but I keep in touch
with candidly sporadically so I must
have been quite something summer 69
either about labs and what was the
feeling that was it like working at one
of these places that so well-known for
innovation yep it was an indescribably
great experience it really was because
there were so many people there who were
so good
and the environment was totally open and
supportive if you had a problem it was
like the quarters of building
everybody's office door was open you
could say I have a problem to anybody
and they would try and help you they
would drop whatever they were doing and
if somebody came into your office you
could you know try and help them with
their problems if somebody had an idea
they would talk about it people would
gather in the corridors talking about
ideas people would meet at lunch and
talk about things like that everything
was totally open certainly in the UNIX
system although there were protections
on files and the file system people
tended not to use them and certainly the
source code for the system was just
sitting there and you could look at it
people had logins but typically kept
their directories totally open it was
probably foolishly open in some respect
but so if you wanted to see how command
worked you could read the code if you
wanted to change it well go ahead and do
it and so it in that sense
was within a narrower environment of
precursor of open source and had in the
jargon of a few years later was egoless
programming in the sense that I wrote
the code but if somebody else can do it
better go ahead I think typically that
didn't happen a lot except by people who
we're working together so no way would I
go in and change Ken's implementation of
something in the kernel no not not me
but I remember going in and changing us
some stuff adding a sub command to the
the editor edie at one point just
because they were something I thought I
could do better that would be useful so
that kind of thing happened all the time
so it was a very very free open and
incredibly I don't wonderful experience
because you weren't told what to do you
were just said go do something so he
says you have to do anything all right
watch available D much space up if you
know what was it just the environment
that was do you know I think part of it
was the environment the environment was
so stimulating and there were so many
interesting things to work on I think in
the background
AT&T member was providing telephone
service for the whole country AT&T had
well over a million employees it was the
biggest employer outside of the
government at that time and that meant
that it was a problem rich environment
there were just all kinds of things that
you could work on and so though although
there was nobody telling you what to
work on
there was always in the background this
idea that she's there's something
interesting there we could do something
with that and I think a lot of people
and certainly for me you would work on
something that had nothing obvious
immediately to do with commute
occasions and then maybe you work for a
little while on something that did have
something and you kind of cycle back and
forth among these other people stayed
fairly pure on one side of you know let
me let's do mathematical type research
and others were fairly hardcore let's do
something that's directly related to the
telephone business all the time but
remember the research part I'll always
call it 1500 or 2000 people was actually
a tiny tiny fraction of the whole
company so in some sense it didn't
matter as long as this collection of
people produce things that were useful
and they had produced over the years
things that were useful transistor comes
to mind is just something that was
useful and some of the early work on
lasers was done at Bell Labs zone
refining which makes semiconductors
actually practical all of it all of
these things came out of Bell Labs and
of course lots of interesting things in
communications as well so given an
environment like that and where
everybody is better than you are you
don't slack you try and keep up with
them I never succeeded but it was a lot
of fun the wisdom for my guitar would
you'll never do it you know our fonts
are not deliberately encrypted but they
are so compressed and so compact and in
such such an obscure format you will not
succeed richer and had mechanisms in the
language to say this is an 8 bit
quantity this is a 16 bit quantity
basically the care and int types that
you see in the early versions of C